hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to a late-night drink
now since I'm losing my voice a little
bit this is going to be a more of a
sensual sexy radio show let's play so
let's go into the confusion side of
things so that I don't have to scream
uncontrollably in both anger and foe oh
I'm here oh where am I I'm in a box
I'm in a box of emotions whoa what the
hell oh my god how is he doing that I
don't even know what's with that bed
with a tiny table by it
that's so weird oh my god hahaha you
gotta be on my hello hi well ain't you
just the cutest little thing I ever seen
in my life well then maybe this will
actually be quite an interesting place
Oh
oh my god that's adorable
that's beautiful that is amazingly well
done oh man why do those have faces on
him okay what are those have faces on
them those are supposed to have faces
these have faces okay good we just put
you back right there how about you no
okay
why do you have faces okay oh okay all
right then this is weird very weird okay
the key wasn't do that okay
I'm mildly disturbed okay which is this
key key from the music box okay there we
go
whoa hello oh my God look at that look
at that look at that
that's adorable oh my God look at this
Oh is so cool hi are you gonna sing me a
song or something much worse
oh yeah I saw you out there before what
are you gonna do for me
seize the key gonna fall out you're
gonna fall wait him back maybe he's
gonna fall out nope
he's gonna fall out no she's gonna ha ha
got you [ __ ]
curious key how curious can this key be
is there anything else in here something
this would be a good conspicuous place
to hide stuff I guess I'm mildly
disturbed by all of the oh my well then
hang on what's that other door
what's this door what does this go okay
no we're never mind I thought it might
have been something okay all right I'll
play your game wait is it getting
smaller oh my god oh that's how go oh
that's so cool oh my god oh my god I
keep going from hating this guy to
loving him oh you cannot do this to me
developer hi why are you facing me get
out of here [ __ ] whoa whoa was that
what is that over there what is going on
over there
something's happening over there can't
open there I'll just have the butt in it
is there gonna be a bun in this Jess no
what okay all right then oh come on I
miss the butt chest okay is that blood
oh are you gonna fart oh my what is that
you have a key in your eye I key hi hi I
didn't mean to take the Ikey
hi okay stop looking at me I liked it
much better when you were farting on me
oddly enough weirdest thing I'll ever
say okay all right
okie dokie okie dokie let's get the hell
out of here now
okay that is so trippy it's so trippy oh
my god
oh my god okay all right then wow I
didn't know that sort of thing could be
done in amnesia oh my god that's so cool
no you come back here you little skipper
oh my little drums to come back here
what what happened was going on here
what what you kidding me what the hell
oh my god oh my what's up where'd you
come from
okay oh wow I can't believe oh I killed
from hating him so much to loving him
this developer you you ass ah why is
this so good I'll go down first sure oh
why is it so good
oh good oil that's useful oh my god I
guess technically that's under the
stairs maybe I don't know oh my god I
love it
and I'm losing my voice but I don't care
I love it oh my god I love it oh it's so
beautiful
Oh was it Oh what oh hi this is my bad
you this is your way of saying you want
me to come into bed with you oh hello
what Oh
oh okay oh good that's so creative oh no
no no no no oh no flashbacks from cry of
fear all is [ __ ] oh my god how is he
doing this how is he doing this
seriously how in the world is he doing
this oh my god oh it's a bag and I can't
handle it
geeks of mind confusion oh hi oh my god
Oh looks like I won't be going back that
way not that I was aching to oh oh I oh
oh my god I feel dizzy chin up we're
almost done I brought back most of your
mind you still don't know how you send
me back I almost have it just give me a
little more time I don't think he's
gonna send me back Lucy I bet there's a
few more places but after this one oh I
love it so much I love it what the hell
do you mean you quit you refuse to tell
us what it is we're working on you don't
need to know the details you just need
to do your damn job it's obvious we're
doing something we shouldn't be and I'll
have no part in it I'm leaving
then Dell with you I don't need you I
don't need any of you I just need my
wine apparently oh never mind then wait
was that it that's all I needed from
anger really huh there's always like one
really short one and then one longer one
that's really elaborate but I'm glad
that confusion was more elaborate
because my throat was not ready for
screaming and anger
peace of mind anger well there you have
it then why didn't you just tell him
what you were doing I told one person
what I was working on it she tried to
have me put in an asylum I was lucky
enough to convince her I was joking yeah
sure
the fools cast away their hopes of
salvation by locking me in this damn
asylum may the rats eat your eyes I am
now lost here cause the darkness comes
it will damned us all continuing from
where we were discussing earlier one
thing still perplexes me why is Anna
here she died years ago if I'm not
mistaken I sense Vincent had entered the
rift when I came to meet him thinking he
had passed away and I could guide him to
the other side I found him broken you
see it's not his mind that has been
shattered
what do you mean well you have been
collecting our fragments of Vincent's
soul is very being that is why I need
all the pieces before I can help you get
back if even one part of my soul is left
here no matter how far away I go it will
pull me back into this place then I'll
finish this okay what do we have now
compassion and arrogance so I wonder
which one I should go in first I think I
have time for one I hope it's not that
okay let's see compassion it is
bing-bam-boom II where am I now
so you're really gonna go through with
this I recognize that woman's voice it's
my landlord yes and now that you've
sampled the Hachi Mara yourself you know
it's real well then
any minute now those were just SaLuSa
nations
I was once naive maybe that hasn't
changed still you've known me long
enough to know you can't stop me you'll
kill yourself
who knows what concentrating that plants
properties such such a level will do
enough have you done as I asked Oh
enough it would do enough yes but it
took some doing tracking him down was
not easy you have your orders
yes I am to keep tabs on him and make
sure this house ends up in his
possession he will be out of college
soon looking for a place though this
would be much simpler if ya know he is
not to know that the house belonged to
his father he does not owe I don't
deserve the privilege of meeting him I'm
not sure I can do this the hour is late
too much so for second thoughts besides
you already drank it yes I can feel
myself slipping away already whether
this works or not I will see the other
side one way or another this is not what
she would have wanted
perhaps regardless I implore you do not
deny the dying wish of an old fool I'm
the son Michael is the son Oh Michael is
on OOP compassion Oh
Michael is a son I I'd asked why you
haven't told me the truth but the memory
has just been restored for me I'm sorry
it's too late to do anything about it
now Anna or mom did you know about this
yes I am sorry I could not tell you
telling Vincent the truth could have
adverse effects I had to wait until you
gathered the pieces what sort of effects
what sort of effects mother what sort of
effects what sort okay the sense of self
resides deep within side the soul even
telling him who he was and that I was
his wife when he first got here almost
ripped apart what was left I had to wait
I don't expect you to understand what
I've done
- forgive me just bring together all the
pieces and I'll get you out of here
again oh you'll never have to speak to
me again
no I think I can understand I've seen
your memories fel your pain I don't
blame you for what you've done but wait
why was that stuff in the cellar I told
Sarah my assistant and your landlord to
destroy the cellar even though she'd
experienced the plant's effects herself
she doubted its legitimacy also I made
cellar several bottles worth of it in
case one hadn't been enough it must have
still been on that shelf I'm sorry for
doing this to you
let's focus on the task at hand what's
done is done
true enough alright I think that's it
for now but anyway oh this is getting
interesting
hi developer you're pulling me in both
directions I love it and hate it you
know the things you do to me I have a
feeling I'm not gonna like this next
part but thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos and I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video it's
Griffin school
uses it for such an amazingly
interesting concept
as a toddler you're scared of everyone
start so they're like these may be real
threats ahead may not be I mean they
seem real
what the full game is gonna be like
because I've added the camp I'll take
please this is gonna be a long game like
at least several hours I think